2024 Republican presidential candidate
Nikki Haley is really struggling she has
now had a week to try to figure out an
answer to what are the policy
differences between you and Donald Trump
and she is still unable or refusing to
cite any differences now I think this is
more about strategy and the possibility
that Nikki Haley is actually running to
be Trump's Vice Presidential nominee
than it is about her inability to
actually come up with differences
between what she would do and what
Donald Trump would do but it's starting
to get a little bit embarrassing so
we're going to look at a clip from Fox
News Sunday during which Nikki Haley was
interviewed by Fox host Shannon bream
now you might remember that last week
Nikki Haley was asked multiple times on
days two and three of her campaign what
are the differences between you and
Donald Trump
and she basically made it about identity
she's younger was the long and short of
what she said refusing to really
criticize Donald Trump and what you have
to understand is that this is very
similar in some sense to what we started
to see in 2015 and 2016 which is it's a
version of ignoring Trump now it's a
different version in 2015 2016 many of
the Republican candidates ignored Trump
because they didn't want to take him
seriously and they assumed if we ignore
him he will go away and yet what Trump
did was he won by attrition as one
candidate would drop out he would pick
up the vast majority of their two or
three percent and then that would get
him to seven eight and then they would
keep ignoring him and then someone else
would drop out and then he would pick up
their one or two percent and that would
get him to 910 and you understand this
is a different version of ignoring Trump
which is we don't like Trump we know
about the anti-maga people in the
Republican party that's who we're
targeting but we're also not going to
really put a Line in the Sand and draw
any kind of Distinction from Trump so
will it work I don't think so but I
don't know that it's designed to work if
you're Nikki Haley and you're running
for VP this is arguably exactly what you
have to do but it is pathetic take a
look at this she says she's focused on
Joe Biden the problem is she's not going
to get a chance to face Joe Biden unless
she wins the Republican nomination
clearly you think you're a better option
than he is or you wouldn't have gotten
into the race so where do you two differ
I don't focus on President Trump and
it's amazing that the media wants to
talk about that so much well it's not
really amazing there are two candidates
you and Trump so if you're going to talk
about this race at all
17 months out or whatever the natural
thing would be you compare and contrast
the two candidates she won't allow that
because she will draw no distinction
from Trump other than his age and his
gender we'll have to because after the
GOP Primary you will have to focus on
him and Governor Santos or anybody else
who gets in to get to president Trump
you will have to get through that field
my announcement was to a few thousand
people in South Carolina I just had
packed rooms in New Hampshire not one
person asked me about President Trump
everybody wanted to talk about Biden
everybody wanted to talk about the
problems facing American families I'm
focused on Joe Biden he's the one that's
the president you know I will tell you I
think Americans need to have options I
think they need a new generation I think
we need new energy going in I think we
need to leave the status quo of the past
and start looking ahead and that's what
I'm going to do and as much as people
want to talk about other opponents
she acts almost like it makes no sense
that one would talk about the opponents
in the race she's running she's running
in the Republican primary so naturally
you would talk about her opponents right
now there's one his name's Donald Trump
will be more many of them are my friends
my they're my friends focuses on
American families how they're struggling
and what remember last week Donald Trump
is my friend listen there's two possible
well the two part there's two reasonable
possibilities here that explain this
other than she's clueless one is she's
not running for for president she's
running for VP and so the way to get in
Trump's good graces is to do as well as
she can in the primary without attacking
Donald Trump that's one possibility the
second possibility is she's counting on
Trump getting indicted and having to
drop out and by not attacking Trump
maybe she will end up being seen the
most favorably by the Maga people such
that if Trump ends up indicted and
dropping out she will they will switch
to supporting her these are gambles I
have no that whether it can work is
predictive in nature and it really
depends on whether those things happen
um she also hears like a bonus clip
during the same interview
she sort of couldn't explain why she was
running which is really just a fail
um check this out this is she she's
asked like why would someone vote for
you and she's like why not okay so I
want to put up something from the Wall
Street Journal this week they said you
had a a great day your great rollout day
but they said you have to provide a
rationale for your candidacy that you
haven't done yet they said you've got to
answer this question about why you
versus anybody else in the uh in the GOP
field you know they're talking about the
fact that you say you know America First
America should be powerful those are
things that any GOP candidate is going
to say so why you
why not me you know I am a the wife of a
combat veteran I'm a mother of two
children one who's getting married and I
see how hard it is for her to look at
buying a home are these credentials in
Nikki Haley's mind to say make her the
president it's in college and I see what
he's dealing with with woke education
you know
her kid is dealing with woke education
so it follows logically that you would
vote for Nikki Haley huh a daughter of
immigrant parents who are upset by
what's happening at the border that's
identity politics of course I don't want
to wait for someone else to fix this I
want to make sure we get in there and
fix this I'm not a lawyer I'm an
accountant I've never worked in DC and I
think it's time that we start putting a
fire under what's happening in Congress
I think we need term limits I think we
need mental competency tests for for
people over the age of 75 and I think we
need far more transparency than we're
seeing today and what I do strongly
believe is the American people need
options I don't think you have to be 80
years old to be in Washington D.C this
is like getting sad this is really
getting said why should anybody vote for
you well why not and it's good to have
an option that is under 80 years old
whoa pretty compelling stuff I really
like the vision of America that Nikki
Haley is laying out here and I think
it's time for us to start getting
aggressive getting back to what it means
to end socialism in this country
[Laughter]
when did socialism start in this country
that would be my question to Nikki Haley
um this is really sad and pathetic and
you know the the most positive spin you
can put on this is that this is a play
on
if Trump's indicted she'll just be there
or she'll be Trump's VP but this is a
campaign that is going nowhere very very
quickly and uh we're going to continue
following it and seeing if Nikki Haley
is interested in putting together any
kind of coherent explanation as to why
she's running one of our sponsors today
is fume fume is on a mission to
accelerate Humanity's breakup from the
bad habits that consume far too many of
us including ones that harm our health
fume is a natural diffusive device that
uses plants and Behavioral Science to
trade out your negative habit for a
positive one fume is not a vape it's a
non-electronic device designed to
transform your negative habits instead
of PODS filled with potentially harmful
chemicals like a vape fume uses cores
infused with plants like peppermint and
cinnamon for delicious natural flavors
fumes new version 2 model is Snappy and
tactile with an adjustable airflow dial
and a magnetic end cap that's fun to
fidget with it's fumes goal to make
switching easy or even enjoyable they
have thousands of five star reviews from
people just like you who have
successfully switched when other
Solutions didn't work head to trifum.com
and use the code Pacman to get 10 off
today when you get the journey pack
which comes with three unique flavors
and the new version to fume the link is
down below